make sure your seat is exactly the way
you want it and feel free to play with
any of these controls up here i have no
idea what they do but i want me car to
be suit car
cameron are you okay you seem nervous
i'm nervous no i'm not nervous
i was nervous
i mean when mitchell made plans with his
father i figured why not spend the
evening with gloria i've always wanted
to be good friends with her on paper we
should be good friends look at us one
spicy curvy diva and gloria
the problem is i had a little minor
setback that we had to overcome from a
couple weeks ago i cannot stand hanging
out with his ivy league friends oh
they're the worst they're not that they
are there are you kidding me debbie
can't go two minutes without talking
about columbia university and the little
guy with the lazy eye from harvard brown
whatever honestly i wish that tart would
go back to colombia and take her weird
little brown friend with her
cam you need to relax you explained not
very well
you know how awkward i get when things
get awkward so when i said brown people
i wasn't talking about your
uh brown people i was talking about
people who go to a university um not
your people not not that your people
couldn't go to college okay now i'm
hearing myself say your people a lot so
i'm just very excited because this is um
you know this is our first night out
together so it's our little date where
are we going
make sure your seatbelt is securely
fastened and your tray tables are in the
upright position because i got us into
paliso
i know it's normally a four week wait
but the matridge is not pilates brother
of mine so just one phone call okay
palaceo
hi cameron you know what i don't know if
i'm in the mood for something so fancy
can we just go somewhere like more
simple oh
yes
yes of course we can
what were you what did you have in mind
you know
how about a little latin place that i
always used to go
that sounds fantastic
i would love to see how your people eat
your people
what is wrong with me
i love this place i was a little bit
worried because it's not exactly i
love
this place
i was nervous i mean there was a lot of
different food on the menu
and on the floor and on the wall
are we sure we're not exaggerating just
a little bit were you there mitchell
because i think i would have recognized
the only other white or gay person
i'd already offended gloria once not
gonna do it again
i'll just have the same thing no no no
no you should have the chicken
enchiladas
no i'll have the uh carnitas diablos
these are not for you
excuse me they're too spicy mr is used
to it yeah he's right i can spice you
under the table any day there sweet
thing
dos
carnitas diablos por favor
okay okay
[Laughter]
but he was one of the best boyfriends i
ever had
but he was gay
yeah i figured that out after the first
month but i stayed for a whole year
because the haircuts were fantastic
cameron is not that funny you okay i'm
fine
are you sure i love this place
but your head is running water no i
don't think it is
i told you it was too spicy for you look
at your shirt no i just need to get a
little bit of a drink no no no no no no
cameron the water makes it so worse no
oh you're right that does make it worse
yeah
i feel like i ate the sun
[Music]
you